bonsoir monsieur oui que j'attends et
vole ma femme et ma fille me rejoignent
ax en doses oui c'est ça c'est par ici
romane melnyk je vais vous demander d'
écouter très attentivement ce que j'ai à
vous dire bonsoir j'ai à suivre
reprenant point par point d'accord vous
arrivez à la salle de contrôle à 22h05
ses téléphones sans votre casque vous
n'entendez pas la demande de descente du
bol un x1 de l'ère du 10 15 qui nous
signale que nous devons et chandon
l'avion à bord duquel votre femme et
votre fille sans monter en a percuté un
autre à haute altitude x12 vous préférez
j'espérais seulement que quelqu'un me
dise qu'il était désolé d'avoir tué ma
famille afin de garantir votre sécurité
il serait bon que vous envisagiez des
changements dans notre vie et notre
maison
un autre nom une autre vie j'aurai
quelques questions bonjour tournée du
recherches n'avaient aucun lien avec
l'une des victimes
c'est la meilleure solution pour samuel
pour nous et j'espère sincèrement pour
toi aussi j'allais retrouver
il a vendu sa maison et les parties dans
un autre état et c'est quoi son adresse
je veux le regarder droit dans les yeux
et lui montrer une photo de ma famille
regardez la personne ne s'est encore
excusé
personne
je suis pas quelqu'un de mauvais n'est
ce pas je voudrais juste que cette
souffrance qui est en moi